seven years later The Witcher 3 wild
Hunt is still a staggering achievement
and thanks to the Next Gen update it's
better than ever the free update packs
in visual enhancements fresh content and
new features as well as an extra coat of
Polish whether you've played The Witcher
3 or not it's the perfect time to
explore the northern Realms welcome to
gamespot's video review of The Witcher
3's next-gen release back in 2015 Kevin
Van ORD published gamespot's original
review and awarded it a 10 out of 10.
spoilers it's still a 10 out of 10 and
in this review we won't be covering the
same ground he did seven years ago
instead think of this as an addendum to
his review that focuses on all the new
stuff
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
while the core experience is unchanged
CD projekt Red has made a number of
thoughtful tweaks and additions that
further Elevate The Witcher 3 wild Hunt
the most noticeable one being the visual
enhancements on PlayStation 5 and Xbox
series X The Witcher 3 has two separate
Graphics modes performance and Ray
tracing performance mode renders the
game at a constant 60 frames per second
while Ray tracing mode limits the frame
rate to 30 but features raytrace
lighting I've spent most of my time with
the PS5 version in performance mode Ray
tracing mode adds more texture and depth
to the world and its Interiors but the
Rock Solid frame rate makes performance
mode more preferable especially when it
comes to combat rolling around the
battlefield countering enemies and
casting signs feels smooth and
responsive and thankfully the
performance mode doesn't come at the
expense of resolution at least as far as
I can tell with the naked eye both modes
utilize a dynamic resolution to ensure
smooth presentation so the only thing
really missing in performance mode is
the raytrace lighting the ray tracing
while subtle is still impressive
Interiors are the most noticeably
impacted by the feature light sources
cast deeper and more realistic Shadows
onto characters and surfaces to create a
warmer more authentic scene Outdoors you
can see the effects of it on surfaces
particularly the reflections on puddles
and large bodies of water it's hard to
recommend one setting over the other as
both have their advantages and
disadvantages the performance option
better suits my play style and taste but
if frame rate isn't all that important
to you then Ray tracing might be the way
to go of course the PC version offers
The Best of Both Worlds provided you
have a capable rig there are a few more
Ray tracing options to play around with
as well as an Ultra Plus graphic setting
I haven't been able to test the PC
version yet but I'm eager to see how
good this world can look on a
state-of-the-art PC the real showstopper
is the new photo mode while it may not
be as robust as contemporary photo modes
it highlights just how gorgeous the
world is and accentuates the improved
visuals you can act activate photo mode
by pressing in both analog sticks at any
time outside of cut scenes the camera is
Snappy and responsive and lets you tweak
the fov the Tilt and a number of other
visual effects unfortunately you can't
adjust time of day and weather or alter
geralt's facial expressions and poses
it's a bummer but the basics are more
than enough to capture breathtaking
Vistas and bloody action the next-gen
version also introduces new camera modes
that are tighter on geralt giving a more
intimate over-the-shoulder perspective
while this camera may not be as
practical as The Wider default camera
it's impossible for me to go back the
world is so detailed and just being a
little closer to the action it gives the
experience more weight the environmental
storytelling is easier to parse
character details are more noticeable
and enemies look even more vicious when
they are right in front of your face
oddly enough the improved visuals the
new photo mode and Alternate camera
angles have changed the way I play The
Witcher 3. I've always appreciated the
beauty of that world but I am moving at
a slower more deliberate Pace I'm less
concerned with the question marks on the
map and more interested in exploring the
world in front of me stumbling on side
quests and points of interest naturally
it's far more satisfying to happen upon
a rare set of armor tucked away in a
cave than it is to plot a direct path to
that same cave via the map this
playstyle is further supported thanks to
the new map filters and HUD settings if
you'd like you can remove all the
exclamation points and question marks
off the map and let your curiosity guide
you you can even set it so the minimap
only appears when you activate your
Witcher senses which paired with the
closer camera angles gives exploration a
cleaner more cinematic feel
foreign
update also adds a new side quest that
feels right at home in The Witcher 3. it
introduces a couple of characters and
takes place in an underutilized landmark
in villain there are a few more
surprises which I won't spoil but upon
completion you gain access to the
Netflix inspired gear when CD projekt
Red revealed that they'd be bringing
Netflix inspired gear to The Witcher 3 I
was trepidatious the world of The
Witcher 3 is such a well thought out and
focused experience the Netflix series by
comparison is not at least in my opinion
I was concerned that this Quest and
equipment might water down the
experience fortunately that isn't the
case while I still don't plan on using
cavill's Witcher gear the quest itself
is a welcome inclusion that gives
context to the new gear and how it ended
up in CD projekt Red's interpretation of
this world even if you don't plan on
replaying The Witcher 3 from start to
finish I recommend loading up an old
save just to check this out at the very
least it's worth it to hear Doug cockle
reprise his role to deliver some new
lines as the white wolf desperate times
for a Witcher huh
thought your church frowned upon Our
Kind mutants the only major change to
the gameplay is quick sign casting if
you have it turned on you can hold down
R2 or right trigger and press one of the
face buttons or L2 to quickly cast a
sign it took some getting used to but
it's now my preferred way of sign
casting it's nice being able to throw up
a Quinn right before battle by holding
R2 and pressing Circle and then
immediately setting my foes on fire with
a shot of igne by holding R2 and
pressing L2 while it may take some time
to build up the muscle memory it's a
small change that does streamline the
combat quite a bit especially on harder
fights that might have you swapping
signs often
[Music]
overall The Witcher 3's next-gen update
is an impressive collection of new
features tweaks and enhancements that
make one of the best RPGs in the last
decade even better if you've never
played The Witcher 3 consider this a
sign to finally give it a shot and if
you've already played it there's still
enough here for the experience to feel
fresh
[Music]